was undoubtedly a genius who questioned
all traditional values
ole life was one t
ing above all against so was against the monarchy again
t the church against the existing state
against inequality against tradi
ional child-rearing against marri
ge and of course against technical progr
ss  in modern terms one could
say he was a professional
obstructionist most of his
life was on the
move or on the run,
sometimes he was hunted by the church sometimes by
governments of different nations
but all the arrest warrants against him were ultimately useless
no one could stop him where  so
wrote the book der
staatsvertrag prepared the french revolution with his demand for
democracy
and became
a pioneer of ecological
thinking through his famous discourses and not enough with that in the
end he also founded a
revolutionary pedagogy which we today
call the anti-authoritarian ore  by the way
, russo got the decisive impulse
on the way to his
friend diderot, who was just in
prison again in the
newspaper marca de france and in it
the  readers asked to answer the prize
question as to whether people would
also become morally better with increasing progress
, of course, everyone answered
yes, except for the man he wrote, he
was inherently good, evil, would he only
become morally degraded through civilization, even with increasing technology
with this provocative thesis he won
the competition and became famous overnight all over europe
because he was the first philosopher who
basically had the problem of the modern world
and the noble savage still roams freely
through the woods we spend our
lives in square offices and are
increasingly losing ours  instincts and our
freedom
above all but so kri  tized russo
modern man only lives in the eyes of
others that means we go into the
mainstream we try
to paint a picture of ourselves
that we hope others
liked so in the end we are right
too conformed and what can we do